here's herman it'll be his 20th start of
the year he's got three complete games
336 earned run average a first-time
all-star and we're going to go on and on
we need the whole ball game to go on and
on with all of his accolades
and that is strike three
that's line to deep center field hanson
is
back there it'll make the catch
and this is in the air right center
field
drifting back now almost having a leak
oh colorado zone the native of fort
collins
marco gonzalez up on the mountain
tonight making start number 12. 1-5
record 588 era for marco
56 and two thirds 49 strikeouts over 21
walks
swinging a miss at the top of the zone
almost the cutter at the top of the zone
85 miles an hour
hampson taking off runs right into the
tag at dylan moore marco look santa has
to sign the stretch and the o2 swinging
a ground ball to third right there kyle
seeger he's got to toss across in time
to get blackman and that will retire the
side good first inning
this one into shallow center field going
out ryan mcmahon to
grab the jam job fly ball off the bat of
ty france for a quick first down
kelnick goes down so vermont has his
second strikeout
two outs for the second baseman dylan
smith and he'll hit a comebacker gets by
marcus barehand pickup story throws and
got him
well the wind-up and the 1-1 for marco's
swing and it's popped up first base side
over to take a look ty france got us
some room over there a little down the
right field line ty is there to make the
catch
on the ground into the shift jp is there
for routine out number two
gets a piece and skims it out to jp
he gets the bunt down it's hard and a
good decision
by herman and a good play
lead off capacity and he takes this one
and bounces it to short
and that's a good decision again by
trevor
in one's head that that's the difference
between marco gonzalez running and shed
long it's been a good year to this point
2-1 pitch is hit on a line towards
center field hampson racing to his right
jumps up to makes the make the catch
pops this up the race is hot
seeger makes the catch
[Music]
back hanniger's way this time he's
underneath it
hampton
tagging and gets into third the payoff
to story
takes it back to the glove of raleigh
and still looking for that first major
league hit cal
banning from the left side against the
right-hander marquez walked in the top
half of the first inning
swinging a fly ball into center field
and shallow this one is going to drop in
for a base hit beyond the reach of
hampton cal raleigh with his first major
league hit
and to center that will get seger down
to second base and get that baseball
kyle seeger wants it from hampson to
give it to cal raleigh look at the smile
on that kid's face over at first base
one-two pitch is swung on and missed and
marcus gets kellneck
002 and there's the slider
and the out completed at first base
swing and a miss for strike three third
punch out for marco
one out the rockies have two odd
for elias diaz here's the stretch and
the pitch swinging a ground ball
crawford at short over the second
there's one the relay by more in time
and there's the double ploy marco was
looking
[Applause]
he swings and hits it well to center
field but garrett hampson is there and
again
the ball with a little more carry and
here to do a little hop to
secure that one but two quick line drive
outs
here's the 2-2
it's on the ground right to ryan mcmahon
good inning for vermont took him only
nine pitches to get three outs
remains at second with two outs connor
joe the hitter
and he drives it to center field going
back kelnick to the warning track to the
wall it's out of here
first major league home run for connor
joe
what a journey that young man has been
on and to see him go yard and give the
rockies a mid-game two-nothing lead i
just love the smile mitch manager to
lead it off against marquez
that line drives
to left
and connor joe
throwing towards
[Applause]
[Music]
it's fun when you're connor joe so
runners at the corners and one out for
cal rally with an opportunity
jumping on the first pitch laced out to
right center field seeger is in
ty france motors into third they're
waving france home here's the throw he's
safe and we are tied thanks to cal
raleigh his first ribbies in the show
two outs and a chance for dylan moore to
give the mariners the lead
there it goes
there it goes dylan moore has put the
mariners in front gave him a cookie and
he crushed it dylan moore with home run
number nine rbi's 29 and 30 out of baby
4-2 seattle outstanding
and left field for a base hit
mcmahon making the turn to third shed's
throw coming in tag seeger got him out
at third
shed long junior showing off the hoes
and left
but seeger hustling up that line keeps
the inning alive for ty france
france
out towards left center field for a base
head terence is in kyle seeger is
pedaling home seeger scores standing
tai france his second hit tonight drives
in a pair and the mariners lengthen the
lead it's six to two
the rockies down four get a lead off hit
cj krom sends it to the bleachers in the
left touch of all time and it comes out
first pitch right now
he gets a slider a little spinner
that just says hit me as it's coming to
the plate and cj didn't miss it so
they're two outs and that'll bring up
trevor story with taffy at second
ravens o2
swing and a miss the slider does him in
and the mariners take game one from
coors field 6-4 the final score